No puedo pensar en alguien que solo tenga una afición en la vida,
y que eso es todo lo que quiere hacer el resto de su vida.
[La forma en que trabajamos]
Un 15 % de los trabajadores en EE. UU. no tiene empleos a tiempo completo
Trabajan a media jornada, jornada parcial, trabajos con contrato temporal.
El término " emprendimiento adicional" parece encajar con este espíritu
donde las personas realizan cosas diferentes para ganarse la vida.
El término emprendimiento adicional aparece en los periódicos afroamericanos.
En la década de 1920 estos periódicos usaban el término "emprendimiento".
para referirse a algún tipo de estafa.
En la década de 1950 usaban "emprendimiento adicional "
para referirse también al trabajo legítimo.
Un emprendimiento adicional es diferente a un segundo trabajo.
Un segundo trabajo se hace por necesidad.
Mientras que un emprendimiento adicional puede traer también ingresos adicionales,
es un poco más aspiracional.
El emprendimiento adicional captura un cierto tipo de espíritu empresarial.
He entrevistado a más de 100 mujeres de color
en Side Hustle Pro
que comenzaron exitosos emprendimientos adicionales.
Nailah Ellis-Brown sacó a Ellis Island Tea de su baúl.
Arsha Jones comenzó su famosa salsa Co Mambo de Capital City
con un producto y un enlace de PayPal.
Todas estas mujeres llevaron a cabo emprendimiento adicional.
¿Qué nos dice esto exactamente?
Primero, que las personas ven oportunidades dentro de sus comunidades.
El objetivo no es necesariamente ser la próxima Coca-Cola o Google.
La escala es excelente, pero también hay belleza en un negocio exitoso
que está construido para una audiencia específica.
Segundo, la gente está cada vez más interesada en ser su propio jefe.
Ser tu propio jefe requiere disciplina.
Los millonarios hechos a sí mismos tienden a tener un gran rasgo en común:
Toman decisiones, se hacen responsables
y resuelven ante los desafíos.
Un emprendimiento adicional es una forma excelente de probar ser tu propio jefe
y ver si tienes esas habilidades antes de trabajar completamente por tu cuenta.
Tercero, las personas son multipasionadas.
Quiero hacer hincapié en que no se inicia cada emprendimiento adicional
porque alguien odia su trabajo.
Muchos se inician simplemente porque la gente está interesada.
en muchas cosas diferentes
Lisa Price, quien fundó una compañía de belleza y peluquería, Carol's Daughter,
trabajaba en producción de TV cuando comenzó a hacer cosas.
Ella dice que realmente amaba su trabajo.
El hecho de llegar a casa todos los días sintiéndose bien,
la llevó a comenzar a experimentar
con la elaboración de fragancias y aceites para el cabello en su cocina.
Siempre se nos ha enseñado
que debemos saber lo que queremos hacer de mayores.
Pero cuando eres multipasional,
quieres sumergirte y meterte en cosas diferentes.
No significa que no estés comprometido con tu trabajo,
solo significa que tienes otras salidas que te dan alegría.
Y eso nos muestra lo último de la revolución del emprendimiento adicional:
La gente quiere apostar por sí misma.
El emprendimiento adicional es atractivo porque es más fácil arriesgarse
cuando tienes algún tipo de ingreso fijo.
Incluso si un emprendimiento adicional no despega,
sigue siendo una inversión en ti mismo.
El 41 % de los millennials que realizan emprendimiento adicional
dicen haber compartido esta información con sus empleadores.
No les preocupa que sus gerentes reaccionen negativamente.
Reconocen el aprendizaje y crecimiento que conlleva un emprendimiento adicional.
Todo el mundo busca sentirse satisfecho.
El 38 % de los baby boomers sienten algún tipo de pesar por su carrera.
Nadie quiere eso.
La verdad es que hay muchas maneras diferentes de encontrar la felicidad
a través de lo que hacemos.
El emprendimiento adicional abraza esa esperanza
de que podamos ser los que tomamos las decisiones
de cómo gastamos nuestra vida laboral.